we will say about you you die I think I
care that were hot and it is more than a
Weaver's we music hazel sense so I'm
gonna memory tickets on and I don't
album unique something if you drink too
much
that into the water please
the truck
watch out for the drop flattop
maybe for you there's a tomorrow but for
some of us there is only today okay
exactly get in no I'm eating out when
you guys big party tonight I'm throwing
out Johnny oh my god what's he doing
here what's this what are you doing what
happened last night
what do you mean there's gonna be days
off you all day long
are you okay it wasn't a dream it really
happened again
the only way to escape to change watch
out for the drug run track I had to do
something that would make a difference
maybe things could change
and maybe I could change them I remember
two weeks are you in trouble you can
trust maybe for you there's a tomorrow
but for some of us but it will make
today but I didn't know any of that
until right before I found
you